welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to thinking
like a billionaire now you can just
watch this video or if you want to sign
up for the entire series for
free and get the bonus pdf companion
calendar
check the link in the description below
today is day 25 and we're gonna learn
how you can find your passion
like a billionaire enjoy
[Music]
i had students last week 160 of them
from harvard and
south dakota state i just tell them try
to find your passion and you know i mean
may not find it the first time but you
know don't sleep walk through life find
something that
you really enjoy doing if you can do it
and not you know
not everybody's lucky enough to be able
to find that but it's it ought to be
your goal but
to make ten dollars a week more doing
something that you don't feel good about
compared to something you'd feel good
about you know make the change bill said
something i thought was really
interesting he said
the thing you do obsessively between age
13 and 18 that's the thing you have the
most chance of being world class at
yeah bill said his one thing was coding
what was your one obsession well i was
pretty interested in investments now
bill and i
his father many years ago right after we
met
had us a group of about 20 write down on
a sheet of paper one word that they
thought accounted for their
success and bello guy who may only met
twice
didn't know what the other one was
writing down we both wrote down the same
word which was focus
and he was focused on software i was
focused on investments and it
it it gave me a big advantage to start
very young there's no question about it
computers when i was young were super
expensive
and my friend paul allen and i actually
snuck into places at the university of
washington where they had computers that
weren't being used at night
and so we were fascinated by what the
computer could do
but very few people were getting
exposure we had to go
out of our way and we were lucky that we
did it all
and so then when the idea of moving the
computer onto a chip
that intel would make and that would
make the computer
literally millions of times cheaper than
the ones we were using so both more
powerful and available to people on a
personal level
then the idea of okay it would be very
different the software you needed the
way the industry would work
we were super lucky to
be there when that was happening so what
did your family think
did they say there's something wrong
with this young man he wants to just do
computers
they knew i was obsessed with computers
that i would
skip athletics that i'd go in overnight
that i'd you know leave the house
sometimes
when they prefer i went go work at night
on these things
and so it was kind of considered a
little strange
and the big moment was when i said
instead of going to
part of my senior year that i wanted to
go work
for company writing software so they
were great about
allowing that to be my hobby the way to
make movies is to do stuff that you love
because
you know for 25 years i worked on the
oprah show
and uh stephen will tell you that there
were date nights that i came home and i
almost you know it's hard to even like
take off my clothes because i knew i was
going to
be getting up four hours later but i
never really
felt exhausted like deplet never felt
exhausted but i never felt depleted
so do the work that comes straight from
the soul of you from your background
from stories that you've grown up with
from stories that
bring you passion from stories that you
uh
not just yearn to tell but that if you
don't tell them they won't get told
and when you when you are operating you
know the single
the single greatest uh wisdom
i think i've ever received other than
when people show you they are
is that the key to fulfillment
success happiness contentment
in life is when you align
your personality with what your soul
actually came to do i believe everybody
has a soul and has
you know their own personal spiritual
energy
so when you can use your personality to
serve
whatever that thing is you
can't help but be successful so if you
do films that come from the interior of
your soul
you do work you do art that comes from
the interior of you
it you cannot miss it's only when you're
doing stuff that you
think might make money you think it may
be
uh a hit or you think it may
bring you some level of attention or
success that isn't what does it i would
have to say that all of the great
wonderful experiences of my life that
have brought me to this
moment have come from working from the
interior of myself
and so that's why it feels so authentic
because it
it actually is so when you do that
you'll win
what advice would you give someone who's
wondering like
how do i find my passion and how do i
pull on these threads and and
where are they going to lead to help us
understand how you got started and how
they should think about it
well i think i mean most um most people
listening to this show know know what
their passion is and
um and they may it could be a hobby it
could be
um you know they could love reading they
could love playing tennis they could you
know they'll have passions
um and if you have a passion uh it makes
sense to spend a lot of your life
in involved in that passion um
and quite often you can turn your
passion uh
into a business you can see um
uh that maybe there's some aspect of
your passion
that people are not doing that well and
um
and you know you can say screw it you
know i
i could i could i could do it better um
and i think all you know if
you spend your life with your eyes open
looking for
um looking for things that frustrate you
looking for a gap
gaps in the market um that's all the
business is is it
it's fulfilling that you know filling in
a gap and doing it better than it's been
done by anybody else
um and uh
and um and you know it it people who
don't have closed minds will most likely
find find that or find those
opportunities
now i suspect there will be a hundred
people who will have come up with that
idea before you
um but those hundred people um
you know won't have had the courage just
to go and do something about it
so um you know so those few people who
just say right you know
i'm going to give it a go um that and
often end up
um you know being being successful you
don't choose your passions
your passions choose you and i would
always advise young people actually
anyone
you know to get in touch with what
you're really passionate about
and it's a gift to have a passion some
people are lucky they have more than one
passion
they have two or three and that gives
you energy
you can't force the passion on yourself
it just doesn't work you can try but
it's unlikely to succeed
ever since i was five years old that's
when neil armstrong stepped onto the
surface of the moon
i've been kind of passionate about
space rockets rocket engines space
travel
i became a science fiction reader
and i've always known that i wanted to
uh
you know do something having to do with
space and i've spent a lot of time
thinking about it
for really almost my whole life and
that's one of the things you guys will
find
that you have passions and having a
passion is a gift
i think we all have passions and you
don't get to
choose them they pick you but you have
to be alert to them you have to be
looking for them
and when you find your passion it's a
fantastic gift for you because
it gives you direction it gives you
purpose you can have a job or you can
have a career or you can have a calling
and the best thing is to have a calling
and if you find your passion you'll have
that and
all your work won't feel like work to
you people look at airbnb and they think
we were an overnight success
and that couldn't be further from the
truth um it's been
a very long haul to get to where we are
today
um three years is a very long time when
you're working
six or seven days it is 12 plus hours
every day
um it actually feels like a decade to me
it doesn't feel like three years feels
like two years
um but my advice to entrepreneurs would
be you have to have
a an uncanny amount of persistence
like almost to the point of
people call crazy like i think
you get persistence persistence comes
from from pursuing an idea that you're
like incredibly passionate about so
maybe we should back up and it actually
starts with like
being passionate about your idea and i
think if you're passionate about your
idea
like nothing's going to stop you and i'm
going to tell you something that a lot
of people 99
of people disagree with me on right
everybody says follow your passions
i say that's [ __ ] right
i say follow your effort it's amazing
how we're all passionate about things
we are all passionate about something
helping veterans helping this
organization helping this group that's
great
but it no matter what it all nets out to
where do you put your time
because when people put in their time
you get better at things and when you
get better at something and get good at
something then you have a chance to be
great at something
you know what i've learned nobody ever
quits anything they're great at
and once you get great at it it's
amazing how passionate you become about
it
follow your efforts right because it's
not in the dreaming it's in the doing
the passion i've always had for business
and being an entrepreneur
the tran that transfers into the mavs i
i've always been passionate
some people thought you know it's it's
more ocd than anything else which i
think is a
a great trade for an entrepreneur um
when i
you know i mentioned the stamp business
i would stay up till
three four in the morning even though i
had to get up and go to school and read
lynn's stamp news and scott stamp
journals and
have them all memorized and and use that
to give myself an edge
um even when i was in college
i'd be in live in the library reading
business books and just looking for
business biographies and just reading
all i could about business
um when i had micro solutions and
you know i started with no money you
know i i pull all-nighters
in in front of borrowed computers
teaching myself software and
and how to program you're not like the
regular
guy who owns a team who just you know
sits on the sideline and
his family can you be involved you talk
to the other team
oh yeah if you try to get him off the
sign with you don't sign you
call him all kind of pun you didn't sign
with me i'm like mark cuban
oh yeah yeah someone talked about it
love it
look you know i've been a basketball
junkie my entire life since i've been
five years old
and um i just get into it you know we
all have something right
where you're just like right just super
passionate right
um and that it's always been basketball
for me i mean during the game
i'm out of control right those 48
minutes right any other time i'm like
this
i think as a kid i was i always had a
kind of scientific curiosity
i was always interested in mathematics
and i was i always enjoyed
still doing math problems and in fact my
undergrad i had a degree in both math
and computer science
and i think eventually i was really
inspired by computers because
of the amazing power that they they give
you i mean today's
pcs do a billion operations per second
i mean it's almost inconceivable
and i think that was the most inspiring
thing to me how you could
leverage that to actually produce
something that was you know that was
useful
uh beyond video games and things like
that eventually
i went on to to join the phd program
computer science at stanford
and those purely you know the interest
of
what can you do with all the world's
information now that it's online
that interest spawned google and that
was together with larry page who's my
co-founder and partner
i would say and continue to encourage uh
folks in just the
next uh generation of entrepreneurs to
be able to
really think deeply about the problems
that you want to solve be passionate
about it and
figure out creative solutions in an
interdisciplinary capacity to solving
problems like in this case
we really had to take a blank slate
approach about thinking about how you
would solve something like
throw out the legacy approaches and how
would you do it to be able to have the
best possible solution
uh in our case it ended up taking you
know eight years you know from end to
end to go through the whole development
cycle of this you know and we had to
bring on a couple hundred highly
specialized engineers to build out
these different components and uh and of
course a significant capital investment
of
you know 250 million that we've put into
through this development to be able to
get to the stage and now
be in this position so you know it's a
journey but you have to build it step by
step
um continue to encourage people to
create you know there's a lot of uh you
know we were living in the age of
consumerism but i have a huge amount of
respect for creators
whatever it may be uh and ultimately um
you know some things are are just really
interesting on their own some things are
meant to be uh
you know businesses in this case you
know we went all in on this and uh
exciting to be out there with it hey you
ever felt like
lost
not knowing where you're going what
you're doing
or why you're doing it
maybe maybe you're out of work right now
you don't have work or maybe you don't
like your job
oh man sorry about this
whatever you got a relationship
could be a bunch of stuff right just
don't know where you're going what
you're doing
hey i want to tell you number one
i'm married kids
would appear to have it all together got
five companies
to show up for every day
i feel lost so
there's nothing wrong with you
don't start thinking there's something
wrong with you
sometimes we just feel lost
so what i do what i do when i feel like
this
by the way it's only hit me like i don't
know how many
how many times in my life i've felt like
this tens of thousands
not 10 or 12 tens of thousands of times
i've woken up middle of the day at night
come up with a big win and felt lost
like hey where what am i doing here what
what why am i doing what i'm doing where
am i going
what am i going there for why is it
worth i'm good man
you know what's the point
okay particularly when you start having
some success in life it's easy to
understand why you're feeling lost
when uh when you're having some failures
and then and then you're like good what
is it worth
you know it's not worth the energy i'm
losing i'm getting disappointed and
discouraged and taken down
but when you're winning it happens too
you know you have a big victory hit
achieve your target or
are exceeded and something happens
something comes in after like a sense of
loss
what i do is this okay anytime i have
that go on
by the way it's happened to me so many
times
i don't think i'm an expert at it by any
means
it's all right
i can't really even explain the whole
thing okay i'd like to
thanks i'd like to give you some
clinical
i'm sure there's some jackhead out there
that'll
give me some clinical professional
advice about what's wrong with me
and tell me i have some issue but the
reality is
it doesn't matter what the issue is the
reality is what are you going to do
about it because it's going to happen to
you
okay what are you going to do when you
wake up and you feel
lost you feel less than you feel you
feel a sense of
either depression or despair and no
direction
what i do is this i show up
i show up man a buddy of mine told me
when i was
at the at a low super low point in my
life
he said hey man show up even if your
life's
if your eyes are bleeding and your life
is low
show up anyway show up show up
is what i do i show up i put it i put a
smile on my face
that's right i put a smile on my face i
try to be exceptional in the space that
i'm in i try to be like i try to be
an example a beacon i don't i don't want
to be the bad attitude i want to be the
good attitude i want to be the
i want to be the uh the example
thanks man hey thank you so much thanks
a lot
see i want to be the example i want to
take the time to say thank you so much
so look if you're feeling a little lost
man just keep showing up just keep
showing up
okay number one show up number two be an
example be a beacon be
the example of positive smile on your
face
extra levels of service and at some
point you got to trust a little bit
okay number three you gotta trust that
things are gonna they're gonna turn
you have to trust that things are gonna
change they're gonna get better
if you look around this planet man most
things
somehow keep working
somehow keep things keep working okay
most people don't get in wrecks there's
a few wrecks
the news doesn't report all the good
stuff that goes on but good stuff does
happen
somehow this planet keeps spinning this
rock that we're on
is flying through the universe
somehow doesn't hit anything big enough
to throw it off course and we keep on
keeping on
so the three things that i do is i show
up first of all i know it's coming okay
let me just say i know
it's going to happen it's like a loss of
creativity
loss of direction don't know what i'm
gonna do don't know what i'm gonna do
it's like my tank's empty what i do when
that happens
number one is i show up number two put a
big smile on my face
and deliver extra extra extra service
as a way to get out of this thing and
number three
i trust that it's going to change i got
to put this phone down because i'm
driving now
three trust that it's going to change
even though i've become an expert at
this
trust that it's going to turn all
things past in time all things past and
time
so look i hope this finds you well if
you like this video please
uh comment on it tell me what you liked
about it or what you didn't like about
it or what do you do
how do you guys handle the lostness how
do you handle the down how do you
handle the lack of direction what do you
do
if you think i have some clinical issue
please post it what's wrong with me
i don't know how that helps anybody
though i don't know how the labels help
oh now we know you're this
and then uh if you hadn't subscribed to
the channel i'd really appreciate if you
did that
uh listen to that southern accent coming
out really appreciate you did that
really appreciate if you would subscribe
i drop about two videos a day on youtube
so anything on sales marketing
uh real estate finance
i want to help people because ultimately
the thing that keeps me
out of the lostness when i'm when i come
back to my senses when the thing passes
i want to help people man the number one
thing
that gets me out of the [ __ ] is i want
to help people when i help people
everything changes for me it's like this
miracle this gift this secret
that that the gods uh
bestowed on us help someone and you will
feel better
okay i think i think one of the things
that happens is it's so it's such a
compelling thing that we want to help
people
that when we can't help people when we
find out we're limited to the number of
people we can help
um it takes a lot out of us i know you
want to help people i trust that you're
a good person and you want to help
people you want to help your parents you
want
brothers sisters if you've ever had
somebody in your life that you loved and
you couldn't help
dude it's a killer kills me
kills me kills me interesting just
thinking about something right now
but it but but it it kills me when i
can't help somebody i love it we either
won't take my direction
can't take the help can't make the
change i know that nothing's going to
shift
but there's a situation in their life
where it just can't i can't do anything
man i hate that i hate that i don't want
to think i'm powerless
i want to think i can help anybody
anytime how many selfish people out
there
let me tell you something the mission
you're on right now this business
mission that you're on this this mission
to to have a
to build a business to take care of your
family
you better get selfish okay you you you
better put a financial statement
together running a business is about
money
period okay it's not about all this
other stuff that you're being told right
now
i went to college spent 17 years my dad
died when i was 10 years old
i have two major regrets in my life that
i didn't get to spend more time with my
dad
and that i didn't serve in the military
i had i had a chance and i didn't do it
because my mom taught me out of it
because my mom's like oh don't get hurt
okay and what i did was i ended up with
no mission and i got hurt bad
from the age of 15 years old to 25 zero
mission no mission
there was no mission in life how many of
you see people doing this every day
no mission no place to go nothing to
achieve no target
okay no enemy no clear enemy i was
working with the pentagon hundred
thousand troops coming back they're like
hey can you help these guys in
transition dude
i said yeah i can help you but you gotta
quit talking about you gotta quit
talking about things that they don't
understand man
okay
okay
this is what they didn't teach you in
school this is the only reason i went to
school
i wanted money 64 of all businesses in
america break even or lose money
listen what i'm telling you right now 64
of every business in america there's 28
million of them
break even or lose money and it doesn't
matter if the economy is good or bad
they break even or lose money here's the
freaking phenomenal thing
okay break even shouldn't be a category
who would make breakeven a category
break-in even is losing
if i told you that you're gonna put a
bunch of resources a bunch of time
you're gonna work your ass off every day
you're not to see your wife and your
kids most of the time
you're going to be terrified every
second of every day
to break even what would you say
look if you don't have your thing
whatever it is the job the money the
girl your goals your dreams
you gotta leave where you are
you can't win a mission from home
we don't win wars at home you understand
you got to go someplace
my daddy gave me uh uh 25 cents me and
my i had a twin brother
and my dad died when i was 10. i was
about eight years old my dad gives me
and my twin brother a quarter
this is years ago this is when you could
walk down the street as a kid
your parents could let you leave the
house and go to the to the store by
yourself and you
you know the parents wouldn't get
arrested for neglect y'all remember that
you go barefooted too right so hear me
and my brother walking to the grocery
store man
dude i got a quarter i'm a baller
i got my first quarter my first quarter
that i get to do whatever the hell i
want to do with my quarter
okay see i wanted to be my daddy you
know why because my daddy had control
my daddy had control you know why my
daddy had control because he had the
money
he decided where we went how long we
stayed what we did
who we went and talked to right
everybody with me i didn't want money
for money man i wanted it for the
control
so i'm rolling to the store with my
quarter i'm all excited about my quarter
i'm like damn what am i gonna do with it
man
okay i'm loving my quarter man okay i
pull i pull the quarter out of my pocket
it flies up in the air and falls in one
of those big manholes
i'm talking about one of them giant man
holes you know where the gaps back back
before the government got involved
and and you could like you could slip
your whole leg down it
man i just lost my quarter man how many
lost some money before you you
oh how bad you want that money back now
you can do anything i'm on my freaking
knees
i'm in a gutter trying to get it realize
how sharp my arms are
i go home i'm crying daddy i lost my
quarter
i thought he was gonna beat me never
play with money son
never play with money how many had a dad
like that
you don't play with money boy never play
with money my grandpa
my grandpa grabbed me he's like son come
over here
let me tell you something man your daddy
don't know what he's talking about he's
got
he's he's got good intentions but check
it out
never go anyplace with one quarter ever
have a lot of quarters boy which one's
right
which one's right look your parents
taught you some great stuff
everybody agree with that half the stuff
half the stuff that geno is gonna teach
lucas
right on it's all good it's like yeah
yeah that's all good yeah that's right
that's right
lucas lucas can't even argue with this
but the other half it's just wrong
the world is changing how many agree the
world's changing right now
dude the world is changing it's changing
so fast
right you got it you got to take the old
ideas that you have and you got to look
at them again today and say hey
is this true anymore is it true
what am i doing what are me and the wife
doing what business are we building
do i need to work for myself do i really
or do i need to find the right vehicle
that can go far enough long enough
provide enough revenue for the right
people
and get to the top of the food chain
maybe you need to do your own deal i
don't know i don't think about being the
owner of a business at the end of the
month i start looking at these i get a i
get a bank balance every day every
single day i look at my money
every day if you're not looking at your
money every day you're not going to have
anybody's money you're not going to have
money worth looking at man if you can
count it you ain't got enough
you need to be looking at those accounts
every day you don't want to look because
there's nothing there
right remember this 64 percent of
businesses in america
break even or lose money okay check this
out 22 out of 28 million small
businesses in america
have no employees zero employees what
kind of business is that man
i am the master and the slave
i am the prisoner the warden the
jailhouse the system
dude you're stuck that's not a business
you cannot do the solopreneur thing
even though you see some guy on
instagram rolling out with a lambo
okay it's [ __ ] that's not a business
a business is people in a company
anybody know any major successful person
that
that didn't have a bunch of employees
anybody here know any great company
that had one employee one flow of income
that didn't use debt okay caterpillar
debt coca-cola debt ford motor company
debt they had to use debt you got to use
debt to expand
you can't stay small and expect the
world to know you it's impossible
how many of your parents told you this
don't get too much attention
fly under the radar don't touch your own
horn be
seen and not
heard dude you don't get attention today
you have absolutely zero chance
of being successful money follows
attention period into story you guys
that don't have time for facebook and
twitter and snapchat and instagram
you're like i ain't got time for all
that how many have said that before
you're like i ain't got time for all
that [ __ ]
i'm busy being broke i'm busy i'm busy
running my [ __ ] into the ground
i'm busy i'm busy freaking with a bunch
of old lies and old ideas
i'm busy paying for my house note for
the next 27 years stuck in one place and
i can't move to jobs
right see i mean i mean one of my
businesses is the real estate game okay
for the real estate game to work for me
i have to be willing to move
you want to be you want to play the real
estate game you want to play the
apartment game you can't buy a product
here in
san diego california right now it's not
going to cash flow there won't be any
cash flow
i want to be in the real estate grant
where do i start you start by leaving
san diego
oh i don't leave san diego then shut up
because you're not gonna buy any real
estate see because you
you don't understand the objective the
mission
the target i do
i want enough money that i get to help
out
when she goes bad okay so i can help
vets
not talk about helping vets so i can
help them
okay i want to do what i want to do with
my money so when somebody like
these guys call me up and say hey man
can you come down yeah man i can come
down man can you pick me up with a
helicopter i just want a helicopter dude
i don't want my money i'm gonna wave my
feet but
can somebody send a helicopter up there
to pick me up i like that
sure man we'll pick you up in a
helicopter good i'll come down here okay
i'll wave my feet right
i need i need money how many of you need
money
okay you guys need to have this
conversation me and my wife look at our
money
every week i look at it every day me and
her sit down and look at her every week
where are we going what are we doing how
much is enough i know that's what some
of you are thinking how much is enough
okay look you don't even need to ask
that question right now
why are you gonna ask that question
that's like how would it feel to win a
super bowl
that's stupid man right how many heard
this before money won't make you happy
how many heard that before you were told
that by who
people that don't have money
so look look my my message to you is
this okay
right now miami's getting clobbered
miami
entire state of florida six million
people were displaced
six million people had no idea
two weeks ago they'd be in their car
driving nine or ten hours in a car
paying hotel fees feeding their kids
right
nobody man nobody had that on their
budget you can't budget all the [ __ ]
that's going to happen to you this year
everybody agree what takes care of that
[Music]
money
so you got you got you got you got to
get re-educated
got to get re-educated okay so a couple
things i want to leave you with number
one if you go to cardoneuniversity.com
bets that's free okay cardone
university dot com forward slash vets
it's free to vets we've had about eight
thousand people go through this program
it's completely free this is a program
that we sell for forty and fifty
thousand dollars to companies i sell
millions of dollars of it every year
it's free to you guys for serving i want
to thank you from the bottom of my heart
for serving thank you so much for
serving
number one because you provide for
freedom for me that that
that like we take for granted every day
and number two because i didn't serve
man i'm like damn man
so i sure wish i'd have played over
there with y'all
okay second thing i want to leave you
this with is this okay if i can help you
on this new mission the new mission by
the way this mission is going to be way
harder
than whatever tour you did over there
you don't know who the enemy is
right okay i'm gonna tell you the number
one enemy for you
is complacency it's not it's not isis
it's your neighbor man so you guys make
it it's a damn weather here
[Music]
the only thing that makes sense to san
diego is los angeles
you guys look great compared to los
angeles freaking nut cases up there
you guys like yeah you see they're nuts
up there okay i'm gonna tell you
something if you're not making the kind
of money you want to make
you're crazy living here you need to go
your family needs to go pursue financial
freedom
it is for everyone folks it is for
everyone i don't care if you're 20 years
old 40 years old 60 years old
80 years old okay today there's
technology today nobody knows how old
you are
nobody knows who you are what you're
doing you don't have to actually leave
your house today if you're willing to
work the program
okay you guys that don't have time for
the instagrama
and the face of booka and and the you a
tuba
okay how many how many of you met me on
youtube you ran into me on youtube okay
exactly you're like dude who is this
dude right how many of you have seen me
on snapchat before
okay some of you like what is snapchat
this old man right here he's like
snapchat
is that a cookie okay the average person
on snapchat is about 14 and a half years
old
probably 15 of my revenue comes from
snapchat when my entire office of
millennials say
your audience is not on snapchat grant
your audience is not
on snapchat i said good but there is an
audience there right
everybody agree right people there's
people
who's got my money who's got my money
okay
we we started a fund about uh what
november october november
okay i got people 14 years old turning
me onto their parents
and they're they're giving me a million
dollars to be part of a real estate fund
kid introduces me to the parents the
parents do research on facebook or
youtube
then they go google search my name they
read one of my books dude the guy's
legit
he worked for toyota and general motors
he's worked with the pentagon
he worked with sprint all these
companies i want to invest in this fund
okay look i don't know where it's going
to come from how many of you don't know
where it's going to come from
i know this it ain't going to come for
me i don't have any money
i got to go get my money i got to show
up in san diego i got to get attention
okay i got to make the main thing the
main thing folks
it's called the top line of your
household
okay i'ma leave you with one last thing
look up the word
economy in a dictionary look it up
it means the management of a household
the management of a household you don't
need to go get an economics class
to manage your household you need one
thing income
now i've got some special bonus clips
that i think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the
billionaire mindset
question of the day i wanna know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
also if you've already got your
billionaire mindset companion pdf
calendar
get ready for another amazing video
tomorrow or if you don't have it yet you
can get it for free
in the first line of the description
below and if you're enjoying this
billionaire mindset series give me a
hashtag billionairemindset in the
comments below
so i can celebrate you there's a reason
why
in my videos i say you have michael
jordan level talent i believe it it's
true you
you have michael jordan level talent at
something you are the best
the absolute best at something
in the world most people either one
don't believe it they don't believe that
they're world class at something
or two they found the thing that they
could be world class at but they don't
have enough guts to chase it down they
don't believe in themselves enough
to chase him down here's the thing you
need to first explore
you need to explore you got to search
you gotta say yes you gotta try things
you don't know that
that tim hortons is your favorite coffee
cup until you've tried it right you
don't know that sushi is your favorite
food until you've tried it
sushi doesn't make sense right this is
how we think our logical brain
starts to analyze things and because it
doesn't make sense we don't try it
sushi doesn't make sense you're gonna
take raw fish
mix it with rice put seaweed around it
and then eat it that sounds nasty
right if you've never tried it before
sounds nasty
but it's the best a lot of the things
that you might be great at
you are a judge and you're dismissing
because it doesn't make logical sense
you don't need to wrap your head around
it you need to wrap your heart around it
you have to feel it you have to say yes
and be willing to try it at least once
if you don't know
what you're great at you have to say yes
and try things
and you pay attention to the feeling the
most important thing is you pay
attention to the feeling how does it
make you feel you might not be great at
it
i expect not to get results at the
beginning of anything especially if it's
a new skill you're learning right
expect a second the beginning you're
gonna suck it's okay it's normal
but how does it make you feel does it
energize you do you want to come back
and do it again
and so for me in helping entrepreneurs i
had my first speaking gig
in in canada at a local ymca
and i just sold my business young
entrepreneur success store i was 22
years old
and i'm speaking at the ymca and they
book off this big room for me and they
have an entrepreneurship program and
they say hey can you come and speak to
our entrepreneurs
yes you know i'm pumped i don't know
what i don't know what to do next with
my life anyway because i just sold my
company
and i want to get back and help so yes
let me come and do it and i
prepare for two weeks making my
presentation and they're promoting it to
their audience for two weeks
and then i get to the building and my
palm's a little bit sweaty and i'm
nervous my heart's beating to get up the
elevator
walk to the door and my heart stops
for a second because i look into this
big room and only three people showed up
three people to a free event and in my
head i'm thinking how am i ever going to
turn this into a business right how will
i ever
turn this thing into a business if i can
only get three people to show up to a
free thing
with a partner but i did my presentation
anyway i prepared i didn't want these
three people down
and it was the best it filled me up so
much knowing that i helped these three
people out i can't tell you how great i
felt
and then we went to the coffee shop
after and continued talking throughout
the rest of the night
and i knew that i had to find a way to
keep going even though it made no
logical sense
and here i am i'm 39 now i was 22
right still doing what i'm doing just on
a bigger level
i could not tell you that i would be
here i had no idea what it would look
like
you need to wrap your heart around it
you need to try you need to first start
by believing that you have michael
jordan level telling us something
that you can be the greatest in the
world that's something you
you can be it and whatever lifts you up
on a daily basis you need to believe it
you need to understand you need to see
it every day because a one-off day
is not enough and if that means you're
watching one of these videos is why i
made this channel
if this video helps you great subscribe
and watch the other videos
or if it's somebody's podcast or doing
an act of kindness and holding the door
for somebody
or listening to you know an audio or or
reading the book something anything
whatever makes you feel
like you believe in yourself and your
abilities even though
your ideas are really weirdly different
compared to what your family wants you
to do
right chances are the thing that you are
michael jordan at is not what your
family wants you to do
because your parents probably aren't
michael jordan what they did right they
settled
and their advice there for is to have
you settle as well
no not gonna fly
i got michael jordan level talent or
something i'm gonna figure it out
and so whatever gets you into that
mindset of believing it you need to be
around daily you need it you need a part
of your morning routine
whatever that thing is has to be in your
morning routine
because if you wake up and did the thing
that made you feel confident made you
feel bold make you feel alive
every single day man your life is going
to be dramatically different it just
will there's
there's no chance you're the same person
in a year there's no chance you're in
the same situation in a year
no chance not if you wake up and felt
bold did the thing that made you feel
bold
you won't wake up and naturally feel
bold you have to inject something in
what is the thing that makes you feel
bold and doing that
every single morning it will change your
life and then when you find the thing
that you have potential at that
energizes you that you love
you go all in on it you spend more time
doing it
you invest in yourself to potentially
become the best in the world
i wasn't a natural speaker i wasn't a
great speaker
it took me 6 000 videos to get to where
i'm at right now a lot of speaking a lot
of practicing a lot of coaching
you can get great at anything it's just
a skill set you can learn a new skill
set
but the thing that will give you the
drive to learn the skill set to be the
best
is the love of the game of the craft of
the thing
and it all starts from you deciding
that you are michael jordan at something
finding your why doesn't have to be hard
it doesn't have to be something that you
spend years meditating on or
contemplating or journaling
it doesn't have to be something that you
go and hire somebody and pay them
thousands and thousands of dollars to
figure out
finding your why does not have to be
hard but it's one of the most important
things that you do because if you don't
figure out
what your why is you will spend the rest
of your life
wandering in circles knowing that you're
capable of more and not actually getting
to the core
of what you're all about so this is why
i wrote built to serve if you if you
haven't picked up bill to serve it's a
it's a pretty affordable book that will
walk you through the process but
as i was going through my tour last year
in the us it was the number one question
that i kept getting over and over and
over and over again is what is my why
how do i find my purpose how do i find
my passion
one of the one kind of variation of
those things right
how do i know what i'm supposed to be
doing
even if you don't pick up the book let
me break it down to make it super easy
for you
your purpose your why comes from your
pain
whatever you struggled the most with as
a human being
is the thing that you want to help other
people with
i call it the book built to serve
because you're built to serve
because you want to serve because you
want to wake up every day
and you want to feel like today matters
i'm
i'm waking up today in the snow here in
toronto look at that snow
in the car filming videos for you and i
feel
like this video matters i feel like the
work that i do
matters and i'm going to create some
content today that's going to go on
youtube and be
cut up for instagram and other channels
and i feel like it matters even though
i'm just by myself
in this empty car just making a video
right
i feel like it matters and that's what
we're all looking for you want to feel
like
what you do matters you want to feel
like today counts and
too often we feel like it doesn't too
often you wake up and
you think nobody cares if i show up
today nobody cares if
i make a piece of content today if i
create a piece of art today if i
make a phone call today like nobody
cares and that's the problem that's why
we stay stuck
that's why we don't get the momentum
that we need and so
you want to feel like what you do
matters
and what matters to you will come from
helping other people
who currently are who you used to be
so think about who you used to be and
what you struggled with right your
purpose comes from your pain think about
the most painful moment in your life
emotional pain you felt the most
worthless
rejected just no value as a human being
for me i'm going back to 19 year old
evan
i'm 40 now since 20 now 21 years ago 19
year old evan
who started his first business
wasn't making any money was full of
self-doubt was
trying to make it look like i was more
successful than i was to my friends
to you know tell them i'm living the
entrepreneurial life and i'm i'm
grinding away meanwhile i had no money
i was having no momentum no results and
was really
struggling worried frustrated
and just thought how did i how did i end
up here
you know where every place where i knew
that i applied myself i would get
results and have success
and here i was planning myself like
crazy and just
nothing nothing was happening no results
every day day in and day out working
working working just
nothing seemed to be happening and i was
too embarrassed and ashamed
to tell anybody around me you know my
business partners knew because they were
they were in the company with me but
everybody else my friends
you know the people around me i just i i
was too embarrassed to tell them that i
was struggling
that's that's the lowest of the low in
the life of evan carmichael especially
when i decided to quit
on my business partner for one day
and woke up the next day and thought i
can't quit yet but that one day was
just the culmination of all the negative
all the frustration all the just it felt
like it was just
weighing down on me every day another
day with no results it just kept
crushing me down
that's that was the worst moment in my
life that was the worst period of my
life
and that's who i still make content for
that's who i'm making this video for
that's what i wake up every day and
trying to help because there's lots of
people there are millions of people
right now who
are 19 year old evan and same thing for
you
you came through a lot of pain and
struggle you're not where you want to be
you're not done growing i'm not done
growing either i'm not where i want to
be yet
that's part of the beauty of the human
experience we want to keep growing and
keep learning keep getting better
so you're not done growing and learning
but what we often fail to do is
recognize man we've actually you've come
a long way
you're not where you want to be and we
kind of get lost in that of
you know we we think about what we want
next and
get frustrated with the lack of results
but you've come a long way compared to
where you
you've been through pain you've been
through struggle you've been through
suffering you've got your story
otherwise you wouldn't be where you are
right now
and people will be inspired by that and
helping get that story
out there and when you've got somebody
in front of you
who you see gets a result when you can
talk to somebody who
is who you used to be and you see them
light up when you see the hope in their
eyes
or you see that the comments that they
leave and knowing that the work you're
doing matters is important
that will continue to fuel you that will
continue to drive you
we're never taught how to find our why
right we're not really taught
in school or our parents how to how to
find our why
and mostly i think it's because chances
are your parents don't know what their
why is
either you know the people around you
don't know what their why is either
and that's part of the mission that i'm
on i want people to find it
i think you've got that michael jordan
level genius at something i think you
want to serve i think you've got
greater capabilities than what's inside
you right now i think you know that
i think you know that you could do more
than what you're doing right now and you
can be
bigger and you can have more money more
income a bigger business
but not for the not for the ego to serve
to help
to change people's lives i know that you
feel that
and so the path is through finding your
why and your why
is your purpose and your purpose comes
in your pain that's a quick summary it's
a quick overview
built to serve goes through a lot more
detail but
finding your why is one of the most
important exercises i think you can ever
do as a human
if you feel like you're capable of more
and that this is not where you want to
end up
you have to find your way let's start
with this purpose
is not passion they're related but
they're not the same thing
passion is also not that hard to figure
out neither is purpose
people just have not been given the
right tools so let's simplify it for you
today
and if you're someone who's struggling
to figure out what your purpose and your
passion are
this video is going to be insanely
helpful for you i have a who why how
process
who is your most important core value
we're not going to dive into that in
this video
but the next two are your why and your
how your why is your purpose and your
how is your passion
so let's start with purpose your purpose
is your why your purpose comes from your
pain your purpose
is whatever the thing you struggled with
the most in life think back to the most
painful moment
in your life what was it what was
happening what was around you what was
that moment
for for positive entrepreneur optimistic
people this actually might be a
challenge for me it was a challenge
because
i don't want to think about the the bad
past i don't think about
what happened to me i'm i'm focused on
what i'm doing now and going forward not
not rearview mirror stuff what happened
back then doesn't matter except it does
because the thing that will fill you up
the most is helping people who are
currently going through
the thing that you struggled with the
most so whatever was the most painful
moment
in your life from when you're born until
right now that you can remember
not physical pain psychological pain
mental pain the thing that made you feel
terrible
what was that thing your purpose
is to help other people who are feeling
that right now
and so imagine who you are now and
imagine who you used to be whether
that's a year ago five years ago 10
years ago
go back to whoever that person was let's
just say it's five years ago
great the person you are now can help
the person who you were five years ago
you may not have all the answers you're
still on your path you don't know
everything
but you've grown you've you've come out
of the hole you're better than you were
five years ago talk to the person you
were five years ago
helping that person is your purpose
you've climbed up the staircase right
you've you've grown there's still
a lot more stairs to grow you don't want
the staircase to end
that staircase is your growth is your
professional and personal development
for life you want to keep climbing
and every time you take a step what you
want to do is reach down
and help somebody else up but you can
only help people to the extent that
you've grown
if you've taken eight steps on the
staircase that's all you can help people
up to get to step number eight
you get the 20 you can help people more
so we want to keep growing keep climbing
those stairs and then keep reaching back
and pulling people up and giving them a
hand that's your purpose
for life you'll you'll like serving
people and helping people and it's tied
to your core value your who your one
word we're not talking about it much in
this video
but you'll just like helping people
because service is hardwired into our
brain
helping people is hardwired to your
brain it has a similar impact on your
brain
as food and sex it's hardwired you'll
like it you want to help people you want
to serve
but who you serve will be different
it'll have a different impact
i love helping people in general but if
you're an entrepreneur that's something
extra special
there's so many great causes in the
world there's so many great causes
why this instead of this because you
have an emotional connection to it
an emotional attachment to it why
because you went through it
because you suffered through it and you
want to make sure that nobody else has
to suffer
as much as you suffered your purpose
comes from your pain
period it'll fill you up for life
helping entrepreneurs will fill me up
for the rest of my life
it will never get old when i'm tired
when i have no energy when i'm depleted
i will still meet with entrepreneurs
because it fills me up your purpose
comes from your pain
you have to find it now let's talk about
passion so your passion is your how
your passion is the things that you're
doing how you're going to actually
execute
against your why execute against your
purpose what are you doing
it's great that you believe an
entrepreneur is amazing but what are you
going to do
how are you going to go about doing it
so for me
it's making videos for me it's doing
speaking gigs for me it's writing books
for me it's helping people one-on-one
for me it's doing
events right that's my how but that will
evolve that will change
right i started doing this helping
entrepreneur thing when i was 22 years
old
and that started just by doing speaking
and then then it became my website
and a hundred thousand plus pages of
content and then i shut the thing down
overnight
and i focused on youtube and it's been a
10 year plus journey on youtube and
and maybe in 10 years that's gone and
i'm doing something totally different
i don't know the how will change a lot
what you get passionate about or to
mel's point about energy what you get
energy about
will change with time but it has to be
connected to your purpose
just because it gives you energy it's
not going to fill you up it's got to be
connected to a deeper source which is
your purpose
and so your purpose stays locked forever
your why
is locked forever your who your one word
your core value is locked forever
how you go about executing it will
change a lot over the course of your
life
right now it's making youtube videos in
five years it'll be something else in
five years it'll be something else and
five views will be something else
as you grow and change as a human as
technology and market
changes as well you need to adapt you
need to adjust you need to change
which is great because you don't want to
just do the same thing over and over and
over and over and over and over
forever and so it makes sense
that purpose and passion are going to be
the top questions that people ask
because you want to be doing something
more you know that you're capable of
doing something more than what you're
doing right now and most people look
around the world look at your friends
look at your community look at the
people you grew up with look at them and
see are these people happy are these
people living a purposeful life
no what no of course not
but they haven't been given the tools
it's not that difficult a problem to
figure out
just go through the who why how process
especially the last two for this video
the why and the how your purpose and
your passion your most painful moment of
all time
and how you got out of it and when you
can flip that to then serving other
people
that will fill you up for life finding
your passion does not have to be hard
understanding what you should be doing
with your life and how you can be
serving other people is one of the
greatest gifts
you can give not just yourself but your
family your community
the world around you but if you write it
off if you write off
finding your passion as being too
difficult not worthwhile
too expensive too scary that you can't
do it
then you cheat yourself up that amazing
gift and you will never be happy
we're gonna fix that in this video so i
wrote this book built to serve
and i did it because i was on my tour
last year
when i hit 90 days 23 different cities
and i went for a different reason i went
on my tour
talking about how to build momentum in
your life and your business and what i
kept coming back with in every city was
how do i find my passion how do i find
my purpose how do i know what i'm
supposed to do with my life
in every city the same thing kept
happening over and over and over and
over and over again and so i don't think
the right thing to do is slam people for
asking the question
of how do i find my passion i think the
better answer is to actually give them a
process
to give people a solution and it just
blew my mind how difficult people make
it on themselves
and they feel like they need to meditate
for years need to hire some super
expensive coach
they feel like it's hopeless and they'll
never figure it out because they look at
the people around them and you see well
the people around you haven't figured it
out so how am i going to figure it out
and if your parents haven't figured it
out
why are you listening to them to help
you figure out your purpose and your
passion what you're supposed to do
it doesn't have to be that difficult and
i started going through this process
with people when i met them
at my different groups and my speaking
gigs in each of the cities that i went
to
and the most memorable one was in san
jose
where i walk people through this process
of who i how and
just the first question was like hey i
don't know i don't know what to do with
my life i don't know how to find my
passion and then walk them through the
who i help process and then that person
started
crying in uh in a great way of like wow
finally having some clarity
and then the rest of the q a basically
was me doing the same thing for the
people
who i have who i have who i have who i
have who i have
and and now people have clarity and
momentum where they didn't have it
before and so
it's why i wrote the book it's why i'm
making videos like this is because i
want to share
the process with you so that you can
find your clarity you can find your
passion you can find your purpose
and turn it into something that builds a
happy life for you
aim for the people around you for the
rest of your life
it's one of the most important thing if
you figure this out understand
that this will never get old finding
your passion finding your purpose
those two things will never get old
you'll love doing those things
for the rest of your life so i talked
about there's a three step process who
why how i'm going to walk you through it
right now
it starts with who so who is your one
word most important core value
when you figure this out it gives you so
much clarity over who you are
to allow you to make better decisions
moving forward so my who is belief my
most important core value is belief
and understanding that allows me to be
around people who also believe
right if you're trying to get into a
relationship or you're trying to hire
somebody for your team or
you're trying to manage somebody who's
already on your team or you want to
attract
suppliers or customers or investors core
value is the thing that keeps people
together
and we talk about it a lot in your
corporate world and
your list of 13 core values nobody lived
they don't even know what those 13 core
values are no ceo knows off by heart
what their core values are and that if
you don't know what your core values are
then you're not living them
so forget the thirteen one what's your
single most important core value
mine is believe yours might be care or
freedom
or creativity or structure or
or discipline right i mean somebody who
values
security as their most important core
value versus somebody who values
creativity and freedom right those are
how you manage and interact with that
person can be very different
you can't push the person of our
security on freedom
and creativity right and somebody who
values creativity
as their most important doesn't want to
be boxed in by security
and so when you understand what your
most important core value is and so
think about
what what movies you like the people
that you love the lessons that you learn
from your favorite teacher all of this
or just spend some time thinking about
what is my most important core value
to pick one over everything else don't
worry about being the perfect one yet
just you have to pick one this exercise
is in the book that walk you through it
in a lot more detail but
one core value understanding that gives
you clarity for the rest
that will never change i'm believe for
life if anything just more and more
believe
right step two is figuring out your why
your why is something simon preaches
right start with why
your why is your purpose your purpose
comes from your pain
this is this is what i think simon
missed in his in his
ted talk your purpose comes from your
pain your purpose
for the rest of your life is helping
people who currently are
what you used to be there's lots of
people who currently are
who you used to be whatever you struggle
with think about
the lowest moment as a human in your
life what was that what were you doing
what were you faced with
emotionally bankrupt like when was that
moment you felt worthless as a person
what was that moment what happened
there's lots of people who currently are
that and you going back and helping them
teaching them giving them hope
motivation guidance
is the thing that will lift you up for
the rest of your life
so again that gives you massive clarity
and then the how is the last step and
the how is how did you get out of the
hole
so i love helping entrepreneurs my why
is helping entrepreneurs because i
struggle too much as an entrepreneur why
am i still doing this how do i sell
energy it's 20 years now of helping
entrepreneurs it's crazy
the youtube channel for 11 years why why
still go why still make
so many videos every day why have 12
different channels oh
hurry this side why have why have all
these chat why
my why propels me forward my purpose
demands it
the how for me of getting out of that
hole that i was in
was modeling success i looked at bill
gates and how he started microsoft and i
learned those strategies and applied it
to my company
the how becomes your passion be able to
teach people how to get out of it
teaching people how to get out of the
hole that they're in that you used to be
in
is your passion it's not that
challenging to figure out
how you execute it may change with years
right so
um right now i'm doing youtube when i
first found this
youtube wasn't even around so i did
speeches and seminars and then that
became youtube and and now then became
books and in 20 years is going to be
vr and some other technology awesome but
that's something that will serve me for
life i'll be 95 years old sitting in a
senior's home or in a wheelchair or
maybe by by that time we'll be advancing
technology i'll still be
you know running around but i'll be 95
years old and looking back and still
loving helping people if you're an
entrepreneur who's who needs belief
who feels hopeless i'll still love
helping that person
get better and believe in themselves and
give them strategies and how they can
model success to go off and do it
and so this is the gift that i wanted
it's why i wrote the book
right if you don't have it yet you can
check it out there's probably a link
somewhere in the description below or
just go to evangelical.com or amazon you
can find it i want people to find their
purpose
i want people to find their passion it's
a much more fulfilling life for you
for your family for the people around
you and it's not that difficult a
process to go through
it frustrates me when people are making
it seem a lot more complex and it has to
be
and when you get that clarity for your
life for the rest of your life
i think it's the most valuable gift that
you can give to yourself and the people
around you
if you want to sign up for the entire
billionaire mindset series for free and
get the companion bonus pdf calendar
check the link right there next to me i
think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there